why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so original sin issue number seven is
going to bring us the second to the end
of the original sin series and what
we're going to get is a lot of
information in a very short amount of
time in this comic book and so this
story is going to go very very fast what
we're going to see is this transition
between the past and the present we're
going to see a lot of things taking
place and we're going to get a lot of
information especially when it comes
comes to who it was that had shot The
Watcher now we're not going to find out
who it was that had killed the Watcher
what the Fatal injury was to The Watcher
we're simply just going to learn who it
was that shot him and we're going to
learn there's a lot more to this story
of original sin than had initially been
brought to us and what we see as the
story progresses is that we're
transitioning into the past we're
transitioning into several days into the
past and what we see is that the orb Dr
Midas the daughter of Dr Midas
exterminatrix and the Mindless ones have
arrived on the moon now again if you
recall our discussion previously in
original sin we had talked about how the
Mindless ones were exactly what they
sounded like they were extradimensional
beings who were mindless they simply
just existed to carry out the will of
whoever it is they could Curry their
favor and at this point they haven't
been exposed to the eyes of the Watchers
so they haven't developed any kind of
abilities this simply just gives us
information as to how it was that the
initial uh explosion of the Watcher's
Watchtower took place and what we see is
that the purpose of the orb and Dr Midas
and and these other individuals being
here is that they intend to rob the
Watcher of his Armament and his arms now
what this means in terms of what they
intend to do with the various guns and
armor that they intend to obtain is
something we don't know but I would go
as far as to say that the only real
motivation here for Dr Midas is to um to
expand his Empire given the alien
technology that the Watcher has and the
fact that there would really be nobody
on the planet who would be able to
oppose him just because of the power
that he would possess what we also see
here is that the orb says they've come
here to be reborn they've come here to I
don't know presumably evolve or to take
the next step and possibly their
evolution or become something better
than what they are exterminatrix replies
that she thought they were just here to
rob the Watcher and the orb says that
too and what we see is that as the orb
in his forces approach the entrance to
the Watchtower the door doesn't
immediately open and Dr Midas thinks
that the orb has brought them here under
false pretenses and of course he gets a
little angry because of it but then we
see the door begins to open up from here
we see that the group immediately takes
off towards whatever they consider might
be the Armory and they shout out to uh
to tell anybody if they find anything
that seems like an Armory in addition we
see exterminatrix saying that the
Watcher watches everything that he sees
everything and so it's important that
they move quick because they won't have
before long before the Watcher shows up
but then we see almost immediately after
they enter the Watcher's Watchtower that
the Watcher appears from here we see the
Watchers say that he sees them and Dr
Midas says to go to plan B in which case
we see an explosion at the Watcher's
Watchtower from here we transition back
to the current day and what we see is
some sort of battle taking place on the
moon this presumably being the battle
between Nick Fury and the Avengers we
see that the Incredible Hulk has been
knocked towards the moon onto the
surface of the Moon and that uh Luke
Cage appears to either be incapacitated
or possibly even dead we also see that
Captain America is sending a priority
alert saying saying that uh The Avengers
are requesting any sort of space fairing
uh assistance because they're in uh in
combat on the earth in the Earth's orbit
they in combat on the moon and that the
target is Nick Fury now with Nick Fury
fighting the Avengers one thing to bear
in mind here is that while Nick Fury is
able to single-handedly combat all the
Avengers and successfully oppose and
defeat them that he's able to do this
for several reasons the first is because
he possesses arms and Armament that are
of alien design so he's able to combat
the superheroes just on a base physical
scale but also what we will see as the
story progresses is that Nick Fury is in
possession of both eyes of the Watcher
and because he has both eyes of the
Watcher he knows all the secrets related
to the superheroes and he's going to use
these secrets against them from here we
transition to to Tony Stark attempting
to attack Nick Fury and Tony Stark of
course asked the question why it isn't
Nick Fury so old and whether or not he
missed anything Nick Fury replies by
saying that Tony star has missed a lot
of things over the years that he
couldn't possibly imagine all the things
that he's missed all the things that he
doesn't know about but we see that Nick
Fury says that he doesn't miss in which
he shoots uh Tony Stark and doesn't
necessarily incapacitate his armor but
is able to uh to keep him off guard for
a moment or two what we also see here is
that the Falcon and wolver rain attempt
to oppose Nick Fury and Nick Fury is
able to for the most part despite being
detained eventually throw them off he's
able to uh eliminate them from being
able to keep them uh keep him confined
what we also see him saying or see
wolver rain saying is that wolver rain
and the various superheroes trusted him
and maybe that's where they went wrong
that they uh put their con confidence in
him despite the fact that they didn't
know exactly what it was that he was
doing at the time or everything that had
been going on what we also see is uh
Black Widow trying to rationalize with
Nick Fury asking Nick Fury to tell them
what it is that's going on to help them
understand Nick Fury says he wish that
he could but he wish wishes there was
more time from here we see that Captain
America intervenes and Captain America
again attempts to rationalize attempts
to speak with Nick Fury and get him to
understand that he's Crossing this line
he's crossing a line that he can't come
back from that there's still time for
him to turn back there's still time for
him to uh come back from what it is that
he's doing but that if he does cross
this line and he stays across it that
this window of opportunity will close
Nick Fury says that he wish he could
explain things to Steve Rogers but that
if he did explain to Steve Rogers Steve
Rogers would hate him more so than
anybody else Steve Rogers replies by
saying that he always respected Nick
Fury that again he doesn't want Nick
Fury to cross a line that he can't come
back from especially after everything
that they've been through but Nick Fury
says that he crossed that line a long
time ago and that he believes he crossed
the line for right reasons and that's
what we see going on here we basically
see this conflict between Nick Fury and
the Avengers both of which believe that
they're doing the right thing that they
have done the right thing and with this
much like Civil War it's Up For Debate
it's up for a discussion as to whether
or not who's right here is Nick Fury
right because he believes that the uh
ends or I'm sorry that the means are
appropriate if the ends are satisfactory
or is Captain America right here and is
saying that there has to be some
standard there has to be some line that
superheroes simply just don't cross what
we also see is that Captain America once
he realizes that he can't oppose Nick
Fury directly due to uh the fact that
Nick Fury possesses armor with enhanced
physical strength calls on Thor and we
see that Thor arrives to uh again
attempt to defeat Nick Fury on his own
Thor says that this will simply take a
few moments or so but what we see as
this progresses is that Nick Fury is
able to single-handedly hold his own
against Thor but again this is going to
touch on the element of uh Nick Fury
speaking with Thor and using the secrets
of various characters against them but
before that happens we transition back
to this to the satellite to the space
station and what we see is that uh
scottt Lang and the various other
superheroes that Nick Fury had been
speaking with before he had retreated to
his laboratory are still attempting to
open the laboratory door and what we see
is that these superheroes are aware of
the conflict that's going on outside
Scott Lang says that they should be
helping him and helping these various
individuals and we see that uh Emma
Frost says they should be trying to get
out of here that if they don't leave if
the other superheroes come back and find
them in here that the superheroes May
believe that they were fighting on half
of Nick Fury moonight says that they
were that they were fighting on behalf
of Nick Fury that that is the truth of
the matter and that some individuals may
still be working for him what we also
see here is that uh when when Black
Black Panther says this when Black
Panther says that some individuals may
still be working for Nick Fury it
appears that he's speaking directly to
Bucky Barnes and Bucky Barnes takes
notice of this and says that he's the
one that cut off Nick Fury's head that
he's the one that brought Nick Fury's
head and revealed to everybody that Nick
Fury was a life model decoy and we also
see that black panther says that in
response to this that Bucky Barnes was
the one who was in in uh possession of
the Watcher's eye the Watcher's eye that
had previously been held by the orb we
also see that Bucky Barnes responds to
this by saying that maybe black panther
missed the part where um uh where Nick
Fury had shocked Bucky Barnes with his
uh walking stick and that Bucky Barnes
had been incapacitated at which point
Nick Fury took the eye but then we also
see the Black Panther responds by saying
that Bucky Barnes had blown up moonnight
ship and for the most part what black
panther is trying to attempt to
establish here is that uh Bucky Barnes
is not really uh presenting any evidence
to indicate that he's not working for
Nick Fury that all his actions up to
this point make him appear very guilty
the fact that he had killed Nick Fury
but took his eye the fact that uh he was
in possession of the eye when Nick Fury
electrocuted him and the Nick Fury took
the eye which could very well have been
something that was set up between Nick
Fury and Bucky Barnes the fact that
Bucky Barnes had blown up Nick Fury Fury
are blown up moonnight ship all this
evidence points to the fact that Nick
Fury may very well be working with Bucky
Barnes what we also see is Black Panther
I'm sorry uh Bucky Barnes accusing black
panther saying that black panther is the
one who recruited all of them into this
investigation in the first place and
that's what's basically going on here is
that everybody is sort of devolving into
this kind of uh situation where they're
all accusing one another where there's
so much distrust here that no one knows
who's working for Nick Fury or who's not
or if anybody's working for Nick Fury
they simply don't know the answers to
these questions and because they don't
know they're all very accusatory they're
all very confused but they're all very
unsure of what it is that's taking place
from here we see that Punisher Gamora
and Rocket Raccoon attempt to leave they
say that they simply just don't want to
be here anymore that there's some better
place to be than to listen to all of
these superheroes arguing amongst
themselves but then we see that doctor
strange chimes in and Doctor Strange
says that nobody's going anywhere that
everybody here is together in this that
they're all part of the situation and
that they're all going to decide
together what their next course of
action is that regardless of what Nick
Fury's reasons were that they think that
Nick Fury or he argues that Nick Fury is
still a mass murderer and that Nick Fury
needs to be taken down for this we also
see the doctor strange says that at the
end of the day when the history books
come out and people discuss this that
they want to be on the right side of
history and so he asks them who chooses
this path who it is that wants to be on
the right side from here we see that the
orb shows up and the orb asks if he gets
a vote here that uh because of the fact
that um uh The Watcher or because Nick
Fury took possession of the eye because
Nick Fury had tortured him to gain
information about the eye that he votes
that they kill Nick Fury we then see
that doctor strange reacts to the fact
that that the orb appears to have a vast
amount of power here or at the very
least has somehow been modified so that
he looks similarly the same but he has a
sort of purplish aura about him and
Doctor Strange asks what it is that Fury
did to him uh Emma Frost comments by
saying she doesn't think that it was
Nick Fury but what we see the orb saying
is that he stole all the secrets that he
stole all of the secrets of presumably
The Watcher including the one that he's
about to demonstrate at which point we
see him apparently use some vast amount
of power or some kind of energy against
the superheroes at this point we
transition back into the past again and
we see that when the the villains the
orb Dr Midas exterminatrix and the
Mindless ones had attempted to combat
the uh the in order to Rob him that the
Watcher appears to be using the same
kind of power against the Mindless ones
and what this seems to be is the Watcher
releasing secrets into individuals and
that appears to be the power of the
Watcher to simply just release secrets
to people that as we had established in
the in original sin issue number zero
when we learned about the backstory of
The Watcher that despite the fact that
his race is very old and very
technologically advanced that they're
very humanoid that they can be killed
and so they're not these abstract
entities we had previously been led to
believe that the Watcher does have power
but his power simply seems to be to just
release secrets to people to inform them
of things that they were previously
unaware of or maybe to even wake up
Linton abilities that they previously
weren't aware that they had from here we
see the orb admiring the power that the
Watcher has the orb is admiring what it
is the Watcher is capable of and he
talks about what it would be like to
have power like that in addition we see
exterminatrix saying that they found the
Armory and that they should grab
everything they can carry and then get
out of there what we also see is that
the orb is again uh completely admired
by what it is the Watcher is doing and
he's almost hypnotized in this situation
and he asks The Watcher if he's scared
he simply says you're scared aren't you
and so we see him take one of the guns
from the Armory and he says the
Watcher's holding back the Watcher's
holding back because he saw but then he
ask what it was that the Watcher saw
what it was that the Watcher had seen
when he had presumably looked upon Dr
Midas the orb exterminatrix and the
Mindless ones when they had entered his
base or possibly even before and then he
guesses that the Watcher had seen his
death that the Watcher had seen that he
was going to die but that the orb had
also seen it himself and at this point
the orb expresses some kind of pity for
The Watcher but it seems to be more of a
uh of a morbid kind of sadistic pity
more so than a genuine empathy related
pity and he says that he can make sure
that the Watcher never sees anything
again and so we see that the orb shoots
The Watcher from here we transition back
to the current time and what we see is
that during this conflict the Watcher's
eyes have somehow left the possession of
Nick Fury and so Spider-Man uses his
webbing to capture the eyes and to uh
keep them from floating out into the
depths of space in addition we see that
Spider-Man comments on the fact that the
eyes are growing brightly that these
eyes these eyes are glowing in a way
that he's not really sure what to do
with that he doesn't know whether this
is normal or not from here we see that
uh again the comment is being made here
about what happened the last time that
the eyes had gone off that the secrets
uh the secret bomb so to speak had been
detonated in which po which case
Spider-Man is talking about how all
these various Secrets had been revealed
to all these superheroes and that uh all
sorts of crazy things were taking place
in addition we see Thor continuing his
fight against Nick Fury and that Thor
says it is time for Nick Fury to explain
himself that his metal suit is not able
to withstand the might of Thor and his
hammer and so what we see is Nick Fury
replying by saying that uh that the that
Thor is not going to be able to
withstand the power that Nick Fury
possesses that despite Thor's vast
strength that Thor also has Secrets just
like anybody else and so we see that
Nick Fury using the eyes of the Watcher
touches back on the Thor and Loki
storyline where he says that Thor has a
sister and he says one last thing he
also says that he sees something else
but before we find out what that is we
see that Thor accuses him Thor says what
it is he demands to know what it is that
Nick Fury is talking about we demand to
know he demands to know how it is that
Nick Fury was able to access the Watcher
secret and so what we see is that Nick
Fury mutters something to Thor he
whispers something and what it is that
he whispers to Thor results in the fact
that Thor loses the ability to wield his
hammer now what it is that Nick Fury
Whispers to Thor is something that we
don't know at the moment although I
believe I have my speculations one of
which but again this is simply just
speculation here at this point we see
that uh Captain America is standing on a
satellite and he's asking if anybody can
see Thor we see that Thor's hammer has
fallen to the ground along with an
unconscious uh Incredible Hulk again
what we also see here is um Captain
America asking Tony Stark if he sees
Thor if he's able to locate Thor C I'm
sorry Tony Stark Iron Man says that all
he can see here is that uh Thor is
trying to lift his hammer on the moon
that he's trying to pick his hammer up
we then see that Captain America chimes
in and uh is a little confused here he
asks if what Tony Stark said is correct
the Thor is trying to pick up his hammer
from here we see that Nick Fury
approaches Iron Man from behind and
issues the override code for Iron Man's
suit to force him to return to Earth we
see that Tony Stark doesn't know how it
is that uh that Nick Fury knew this but
we see that Tony Stark's suit
immediately takes off for the planet
Earth uh removing uh Iron Man from the
conflict that's taking place on the moon
at the this point um we see that Captain
America doesn't really know what's going
on here he's asking Tony where he's
going but he's not getting any response
from Tony Stark's suit what we also see
here is that uh that Spider-Man is
simply just floating out into space and
again This lends Credence to the real
place of Spider-Man in the Marvel Comics
and while it's not necessarily a popular
opinion the fact that Spider-Man is
simply floating out into space and can
do nothing there's no one that can help
him shy of anybody flying out to grab
him and bringing him back I think is a
testament to the fact that in a lot of
ways Spider-Man is uh is part of a group
that is way above his League that for
the most part he can't really maintain
with these major uh space fairing
Adventures from here we transition back
to Captain America and Captain America
again is speaking with uh with Nick Fury
and Captain America here is trying to uh
trying to rationalize once again with
Nick Fury but Nick Fury at this point
has laid waste to pretty much all of the
Avengers because at this point we have
the Incredible Hulk who is unconscious
on the moon we have Thor who's no longer
able to wield his hammer Iron Man's suit
has been sent back to the planet Earth
Spider-Man is floating out into space
and he tells Captain America about how
Wolverine had murdered one of his own
children about how Natasha Romanov uh is
more like Captain America than she is
like Nick Fury and that for some reason
or another this secret or the secret he
had revealed to her had put her in a
place to where she's just simply no
longer interested in fighting anymore
that she's no no longer capable of
fighting and so between the power that
Nick Fury possesses given his suit and
his Armament and the secrets that he has
revealed to various superheroes all of
the Avengers have in effect been
defeated and so what we see is that um
uh Nick Fury says to um to Captain
America that he's going to bring an end
to this conflict that years ago he had
watched a man die and that this man had
asked him when he's uh speaking about
woodro McCord about whether or not all
of it was worth that everything that he
had done was worth uh the result that
the ends had Justified the means and
Nick Fury says that he didn't have
previously and that he wish he had said
yes he wish he told him that yes it was
worth it that sometimes it takes the
worst of people to walk the worst of
roads in order for the best people to
follow and to do the things that can be
left behind to do the things to make the
rational decisions as to whether or not
this should still be maintained and so
what we see is Nick Fury saying his
goodbye to Captain America he says he's
very glad that he met him and he says
goodbye from here we see that um Nick
Fury turns the the comms turns the
communications of his suit off and sets
a course towards the Moon from here we
see that Dr Midas exterminatrix and the
Mindless ones have landed on the moon
they have re-entered the conflict of The
Original Sin story and we see that what
they're going to do is in effect take
everything they're going to do
everything they can at this point we see
that the Incredible Hulk reawaken
but then the orb uses whatever power he
has at his possession presumably again
to uh use people's Secrets against them
to uh incapacitate The Incredible Hulk
once more and again we see that Thor is
continuing to try to pick up his hammer
at this point we see the orb telling us
that this is the reason why he's here
that his dreams had led him to this
place that he was meant to be here and
that he's here to see the Watcher's last
secret from here we transition back to a
few days ago again and we see that Nick
Fury has arrived on the Watcher's
Watchtower after the explosion that had
taken place in order to investigate what
it is that had gone on and what we see
is that Nick Fury is communicating with
one of his life model decoys saying that
um that he thought it was a good idea or
he knew it was a good idea to have
bugged the place that he knew it was a
good idea to um to set um devices in
here to where you could constantly
monitor what it is that was going on but
the question that has to be asked here
is did The Watcher allow this to happen
because of the Watcher sees everything
The Watcher had to have known that Nick
Fury had entered his base and planted
bugs in order to keep an eye on him and
The Watcher was simply okay with this
which begs the question why was this
okay with the Watcher or was this
something The Watcher simply just wasn't
concerned about from here we see that as
Nick Fury states that he's going into
the EV to the watchtowers or the
Watchers Watchtower that one of his life
model decoys asked the question of
whether or not it's a good idea that
given his physical condition the fact
that he's not as agile as he used to be
and his past uh history with the Watcher
as to whether or not it's something that
he should do but what we see is that
Nick Fury tells his life model decoy
that or one of his life model decoys
that if he doesn't come back that if he
dies in The Watchtower to contact all
the Avengers and to inform them what it
is that's been going on all this time
which basically means that he would have
his life model decoy communicate to them
that he is a life model decoy that all
these life model decoys exist they
haven't really dealt with the Nick Fury
with the real Nick Fury for quite some
time and the Nick Fury has been
traveling around the around various
dimensions of the universe and the
interior of the planet Earth doing
everything that he had previously
admitted to he tells the life model
decoy to simply just reveal to him to
the Avengers the Unseen to tell them
exactly everything that's been going on
and what we see is that when he enters
the Watchtower he realizes that there
has been some kind of a Breakin he
realizes that someone has gone in here
and stolen almost all the arms and
Armament that the Watcher had but the
Watcher at this point is still alive and
he's saying that for the most part that
the Watcher probably did his best to
fight these forces off but that the
Watcher wasn't able to stop him stop
them on his own from here we see that
the Watcher takes note of Nick Fury and
Nick Fury is a little shocked to uh
shocked to see this The Watcher or Nick
correctly guesses that the Watcher says
that he didn't simply just do this that
uh that he didn't simply just do this to
mock Nick Fury that he didn't remove one
of his eyes to make fun of Nick Fury he
asked what it was that happened here he
asked Nick asked the Watcher what is it
that's taken place to tell Nick Fury
what it was that he saw from here we see
that Nick Fury that we transition back
to Nick Fury as he's entering his base
and Nick Fury simply says that even back
then the Watcher must have known what it
was that was going to happen The Watcher
must have been aware of what it was that
was going to take place presumably the
fact that he was going to die and Nick
Fury says that at least this time that
at least when he enters the Watcher's
base that there's not going to be
anybody watching but what we see what
Marvel reveals to us is that there are
multiple Watchers watching this entire
conflict take place that all these
Watchers are monitoring Nick Fury
entering the Watcher's base and that
presumably they've been monitoring the
conflict the entire time with that being
said we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and what we'll see
with Issue Number Eight is the
conclusion to original sin and we will
basically have a multitude of questions
answered but with the way the original
sin event will end we will have more
questions than the questions that we had
had answered when the entire original
sin event took place with that being
said I'm going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later
[Music]
peace w